معنا الان من وارسو الجنرال المتقاعد
يرسلاف استروزيك وهو نائب رئيس مديريه
الاستخبارات في النيتو سابقا والمدير
السابق للابحاث للمخابرات العسكريه
البولنديه اهلا بك جنرال بدايه كيف يمكن
التفسير تفسير تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن فيما يتعلق بعدم الاستعداد
الاوكراني للانضمام لحلف الناتو وكذلك
المخاوف مخاوف اعضاء الحلف من خطوه كهذه
قد تدخل الدول الاعضاء في حرب مع روسيا
تصريح الرئيس بايدن صحيح اوكرانيا ليست
مستعده من الجانب السياسي
بشكل كامل للانضمام الى حلف النيتو بانه
ليس ليس تحكم في حدودها
تجاه روسيا بتوعه الحال لكن من ناحيه اخرى
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه جاهزه تماما
وتستجيب لمعايير حلف الناتو لكي تكون لكي
تنضم الى هيكل عمل حلف النيتو اذا هذه هذا
التصريح سياسي
بحث وهو يمكن ان يتغير اذا كان هناك او في
وقت غير طويل وتصريح سياسي بحث لكن على
ارض الواقع اليست الدول الغربيه هي في حرب
فعليه مع روسيا وان كانت غير مباشره من
خلال تقديمها كل ذلك الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا
بطبيعه الحال الدعم العسكري الكامل
والمعدات التي ترسل الى بولندا وغيرها من
القنوات مرور الى اوكرانيا
بدونها لن تكون قادره على الدفاع عن
اراضيها وهذا واضح لجميع ملاحظي هذه الحرب
بطريقه ما اعضاء حلف النيتو
معنيون بهذه الحرب ولكن ليسوا هم فقط
فهناك بلدان اخرى
اذا هذا نقاش دقيق لانه بشكل ما روسيا
تريد ان تعتبر حلف الناتو كطرف في هذا
النزاع لكن هذا اعتداء روسي ونحن
ندعم البلد المعتدى عليه
ونقدم لاوكرانيا جميع الدعم والمعدات التي
تحتاجها
وخاصه ما تقرر مؤخرا
طائرات وايضا اعلان
احدث
متفجره او احدث الذخائر العنقوديه وقد
اتيت على ذكر روسيا التي تريد لحلف الناتو
ان يكون طرفا في هذا النزاع تصريح من هذا
النوع
ويقول يعني الرئيس الامريكي ايضا من خلاله
بان ليس هناك اجماع على انضمام اوكرانيا
لذلك الحلف الا يخدم الاجنده الروسيه
والتي وجدت في طلب اوكرانيا الانضمام
ذريعه لحربها
بطبيعه الحال حلف الناتو يحتاج الى توافق
كامل
وقمه
سوف يحاولون
القيامه بذلك
لتاكيد توافق وتناسق بين
جهود اعضاء حلف الناتو
ما يتعلق الامر بمشاركه السويد في اجتماع
حلف النيتو وكما قلنا
هناك مساله حساسه تتعلق بعضويه اوكرانيا
اذا
لدينا الان 31 عضوا
ومن الصعب ان اتفق جميع الاعضاء على جميع
المسائل لنكون واضحين حلفا لم يفشل ابدا
في اي باي طريقه كانت
وما تزال اكثر
تحالف عسكري مصداقيه
وبوتين يعرف ذلك جيدا لذلك هو خائف من حلف
الناتو
هناك بعض الخلافات او الاختلافات في
حلف النيتو
المجر والى حد ما تركيا شكرا لك جنرال
الجنرال المتقاعد
نائب رئيس مديريه الاستخبارات في النيتو
سابقا والمدير السابق للابحاث في
المخابرات العسكريه البولنديه كنت معلم